un père noël presque normale à la place
versailles
si ce n'est de celui d'un qui astique la
boîte de plexiglas où siège le
personnage ce noël les deux tiers des
canadiens prévoient se rendre en magasin
malgré lakovic 19
le magasinage a déjà commencé pour
certains parce que j'ai pas envie d'être
là en même temps qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens que si on a peur que ça ressemble
donc on s'y prend à l'avancé pour éviter
la cohue du vendredi fou les commerçants
étalent leurs rabais les promotions
qu'on a commencé plus chez magasinage
sur internet vont peut-être permettre
qui est moins d'attroupement cette
journée là autre stratégie
la ligne d'attenté virtuelle on a
plusieurs de nos détail a qui sont qui
participent à notre programme cf liste
des invités qui est au programme des
réservations de places en ligne
d'appendre virtuel donc ils peuvent
planifier des rendez vous avec certaines
aux détaillants ce qui va leur permettre
de réduire la tente et de vraiment de
pouvoir est extrêmement efficace tout
pour aider le commerce au détail tout de
même en progression depuis sa chute en
avril dernier
oui certains secteurs ont réussi à
rattraper les pertes de début d'année
mais d'autres secteurs comme la mode
comme accessoire les voyages sont des
secteurs qui ratera propose qu'ils ont
peur des boudins les canadiens comptent
dépenser en moyenne moins que l'an
dernier due à la pandémie 100 dollars de
moins selon le conseil canadien du
commerce de détail
cette année il faut magazine et au
magazine in localement martèlent les
autorités on évite les commerçants à
chercher davantage comme comme
commerçants québécois peut être que les
gens ne sortent pas qu'une bannière ou
une autre sur des bannières québécoise
dès la fin novembre le gouvernement
prolongera les heures d'ouverture des
magasins jusqu'à 22 heures la semaine et
21h la fin de semaine mais seulement
pour la collecte des achats faits en
ligne
ici marie josée paquet comme radio
canada montréal